hallo Leute und willkommen in der
Weihnachtsbäckerei heute testen wir den
Adventskalender von super Streuseln
bevor ich diesen Namen aber jetzt ganz
oft sage dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses Videos
nicht gesponsert zu Recht fragt ihr euch
jetzt aber Vanessa das ist ein
streuselkalender was willst du uns da
präsentieren
meine selbstgemachten Plätzchen und wir
probieren die Streusel aus
und das ist Zuckerguss und damit ist es
nicht nur ein Adventskalender auspack
Videos sondern auch gleich ein kleines
back und deko-tutor ernsthaft ich habe
die Plätzchen vorhin gebacken und ich
bin so in Weihnachtsstimmung gekommen
dass ich mir dachte wenn also wenn dann
heute ein weihnachtlichen Pulli und weil
schon fast in einem Monat Weihnachten
ist willkommen in der Weihnachtsbäckerei
in der Weihnachtsbäckerei
ausverkauft hat er mich 94 Euro gekostet
wie 94 € für Streusel ausgegeben ja ich
habe 95 Euro für diesen Adventskalender
ausgegeben in dem sich wahrscheinlich
nur Streusel befinden aber die Streusel
von superstreusel sind ja nicht ganz
normale
08/15 Streusel das sind super Streusel
und damit ist alles gesagt wir legen
direkt los der Kalender hat ein
wunderschönes Design excuse more es ist
ein super süßes Ginger bread-haus
Lebkuchenhaus
also super Streusel hatten wir auch in
dem Möbel Höffner Adventskalender also
eine packungsstreusel wow Streusel ja
jetzt könnt ihr mal sehen was da so drin
ist haben die streuselmischung irgendwie
besondere Namen mit Schokoladenkugeln da
seht ihr mal das sind keine normalen
Streusel also 90 g Kosten 7,90 €, das
sind 55 Gramm das heißt das ist weniger
als man im Shop bekommt ich werde jetzt
für alle glaube ich den gleichen Preis
berechnen weil die Streusel kosten alle
7,90 €
4,83 €, das ist schon nicht ohne ne
welches Plätzchen suchen wir uns aus
zehn Tiere Weihnachten wir fangen mal
mit diesem Plätzchen an oi das hätte ich
ein bisschen flüssiger machen können
aber die Profis machen sehr so dass sie
es erstmal am Rand ausfüllen ne und dann
haben Sie eigentlich eine flüssigere
Variante die Sie dann den lieben bitte
machen ich habe immer Angst dass mein
Zuckerguss zu flüssig wird und dann
mache ich immer so mega und flüssig 20
Minuten später so ich habe jetzt noch
mal flüssiger Zuckerguss gemacht und
jetzt kann ich das für die Ränder
benutzen und dann flüssigen Zuckerguss
rein wie die Profis
oh toll das sieht doch super ach ja so
hier haben wir jetzt unseren Keks sorry
ne das sind nicht einfach nur
irgendwelche Streusel Leute das sind
4,80 € Streusel super special Motiven
drauf
ja jetzt ist für mich offiziell
Weihnachten ich bin drin oder was das
ist äh Plätzchen Nummer eins
Motivauswahl finde ich sehr gut da sind
teilweise aber echt großes Streusel drin
wie z.B der hier vorne oder diese Kugel
die sind so zum Vergleich zu den anderen
riesig und ich muss aufpassen wie ich
das halte Nummer zwei erdbeertraum
knusperperlen so schnellen Perfektion
von Kuchen Cupcakes und Keksen Eis und
Co das ist ja was ganz anderes das ist
wieso das größte Streusel was ich je
gesehen habe der größte
das schmeckt wie immer Kugel mit Erdbeer
boah das ist super lecker ja das ist
halt so eine Erdbeer knusperkugel ich
nehme jetzt einfach diesen runden und
macht ihn so drauf nein nein nein
und die innen rein
so und dann machen wir einfach
süß aus ist das nicht ein super
weihnachtliches Plätzchen
3 Euro 30 Nummer 3 Tannenbaum Streusel
ja ich habe extra Tannenbäume aus
gestanzt damit ich ein Tannenbaum
benutzen kann was für eine tolle
Mischung 4,83 €
auf ein Tannenbaum drauf irgendwas lösen
diese super Streusel in mir aus mein
Hirn ist so richtig zufrieden muss ein
bisschen weniger machen weniger ist mehr
Nummer 4 super
streuseltrip okay hier sind wirklich
nicht nur Streusel drin übertrieben
schön Flasche in die Mikrowelle legen 30
Sekunden bei 800 Watt erhitzen Deckel
abflasche drücken und dann kann man so
ein drip machen so ein Kuchen oder sowas
und Cupcakes das Design spricht mich
einfach komplett an das ist so cute und
so da hat man gleich das Backen 130 130
7,90
also bis jetzt aber eine tolle Auswahl
ne Streusel dann die knusperkugeln
Streusel dann der drip und jetzt kommt
wieder Stress und jetzt zu einem
Gold die auch alle so ganz
unterschiedlich vom Thema Aussehen
Funkel Funkel heißen die das ist so Mond
und Sterne und Gold und
wow wie gesagt ich darf nicht
übertreiben ne nicht übertreiben
irgendwann ist Schluss wenn Schluss ist
Schluss stell dich mal vor ihr bringt
irgendwie ein Plätzchen und der hat
solche Streusel drauf das schreit doch
schon ich habe Geld Türchen Nummer sechs
Nikolaus Türchen das befindet sich hier
oben im Dach na klar da gibt's ein
Ausstecher eine Kugel mit einem Loch ich
glaube das kann man dann wirklich sich
aufhängen wie cool wenn man so
selbstgemachte Plätzchen am Baum hat 4 €
aber keine Sorge super Streusel ich habe
mich ausgeschlossen
kein weihnachtliches Thema müsst diese
Streusel sind so ja orange pink hier
unten sind halt die ganze Zeit diese
kleinen Streusel und so an der Seite und
oben sieht man die größeren Teile aber
das packe ich in die verlosungsbox denn
die verletzte Verlosung findet jetzt
statt auf meinem Instagram Kanal da
könnt ihr Adventskalender gewinnen die
ich zusammengepackt habe und weil das
jetzt kein winterliches Thema ist werde
ich das da jetzt nicht drauf machen
sondern verlosen Türchen Nummer 8 oh
geil
knusperkugeln scheiße ich hätte mal
diese knusperkugeln drauf machen sollen
also dagegen wirken die ja völlig
unpassend die sehen aus wie
Christbaumkugeln 30 Türchen Nummer 9
bekannterweise das beste Türchen in
einem Adventskalender und wir machen es
auf
weihnachtlich ich liebe weihnachtliche
Streusel eisblümchen ja das würde ich
auch sagen wo kommen meine eisblümchen
drauf natürlich auf dem Schneemann Leute
das sind doch Elsa Streusel bei solchen
Kugeln die wieso Metall Aussehen ne
eigentlich immer wie kann man wie kann
das essbar sein oh mein Gott
ein bisschen weint mein
perfektionistisches Herz dass ich nicht
so ganz entscheiden kann wo was hinfällt
bisschen mein Zuckerguss ist ein
bisschen zu flüssig den ich so für
dieses innere habe daran sieht man dass
teilweise sich die Streusel so ein
bisschen abfärben wollen wir notieren
den Preis hier Euro 89 € und machen
weiter mit Türchen Nummer zehn
diese streuselmischung hat diese Pop
Rocks da drin die glaube ich so
knusprand glaube ich oder sind einfach
nur so Zuckerstücke
olle Farbpalette jetzt ist die Frage die
werden wahrscheinlich nicht so teuer
sein wie diese weihnachtlichen ne weil
da keine großen Kugeln oder so drin sind
drei Euro 60 Kirche Nummer
Glasur rosa bunte Zuckerglasur als
Pulver zum Anrühren mit Wasser für
schnelles Dekorieren von Keksen
Blechkuchen und Co also leute das ist
Puderzucker wo Lebensmittelfarbe schon
mit gemischt ist muss man jetzt nicht
wirklich kaufen das ist ganz einfach zu
Hause gemacht ich mache 3 € keine Ahnung
Halbzeit und wir bekommen
Überraschung zum blau lila Farbmix also
so Farben finden
die gut zusammenpassen das können die oh
das hat sowas Meerjungfrauen mäßiges
oder Schälchen in Nummer 13 Mandeln in
weißer Schokolade okay was muss ich mit
Mandeln in weißer Schokolade dekorieren
so schnellen Perfektion von Kuchen
Cupcakes und Keksen Vollmilchpulver gib
ihm oh riechen riech mal riechen gut ne
finde ich auch
hmm die sind super lecker was geht denn
mit denen aber kommen die dann plötzlich
so mit Mandeln um die Ecke die mit
Schokolade umgezogen sind ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz lecker nee die Mandeln
haben sie doch nicht drin ich mach mal 4
€, ne da ist ja alles so ein bisschen
teuer
14 man sieht ja eigentlich auch auf dem
Sticker schon immer ungefähr was drin
sein wird also hier sind so Krönchen und
Herzen und so muss man das gar nicht so
sehen aber ich dachte Valentinstag aber
das ist für eine kleine oder ein kleines
Prinzessin je nachdem
4,83 € übrigens Nummer 15 ist super lang
kommen die plötzlich mit einem Buch um
die Ecke meine super Rezepte gut
abreißen das ist wirklich super cute das
einzige was ich mich frage ist weil die
zum Abreißen sind wohin dann damit ne
also ich kann da echt nichts gegen sagen
das ist wirklich tolles Buches
Rezeptbuch das gibt's nicht ich mache
mal 4 € bei allem was ich nicht weiß 4 €
frühlingsstreusel mit Schmetterling
grünen Kugeln und alles was der Frühling
so mit sich bringt gut ich hatte mich
schon nämlich gewundert und dachte okay
wenn da jetzt nur weihnachtliche
Streusel drin sein würden womit ich
jetzt kein Problem gehabt hätte dachte
ich aber dann kann man sie ja
wahrscheinlich nicht alle in dem
Zeitraum verwenden in dem man diesen
Kalender auspackt aber so hat man schon
fünf Frühling und für andere Anlässe
auch Streusel und plötzlich ist man die
verrückte mit der Streusel Obsession oh
mann
wow Streusel hätte ich nicht gedacht ne
grinsebacke Bio und Veganer
Zuckerstreusel Mix oh toll hier auch was
für die Bio und Veganer also die
Streusel die gebe ich auf jeden Fall
meine Managerin anni weil sie ist
Veganerin und ich glaube in den meisten
Streuseln sind dann noch so
farbfärbungsmittel und sowas ich würde
jetzt spontan sagen für so ein
Zitronenkuchen oder so würde ich diese
Streusel benutzen aber
Bio und vegan was machen wir da machen
wir da die kleine Portion ne 330 ich
komme mir aber auch mal vor wie auf dem
Flohmarkt wenn ich in Sachen notiere 18
oh mein Gott super Glitzer Puder das ist
die Portion mit der ich gerechnet habe
ah und jetzt so ein das finde ich cool
dass man gar nicht so mit dem Pinsel
sondern
kommt Leute wir probieren es aus die
Glocke bekommt goldenes Bruder aber
erstmal eine ordentliche Schicht Zucker
du bist ein Zauberer Harry boah ist das
schön möchte gucken kann
es war schön da und jetzt lass uns
richtig
goldener Keks jo das sieht richtig
hässlich aus
[Musik]
oh 19 okay Streusel süß rosa 4,83 €. 20
ganz wilder Mix das sieht aus wie
Kieselsteine raus und raus das sind so
Kristalle aber die sehen ein bisschen
aus wie Steine nette Mischung aber kein
weihnachtsthema und 20 Keks Kugeln Creme
Brulee das haben die hier schon wieder
da ist ein kleiner Keks drin oh mein
Gott schmeckt das gut wer produziert
diese Sachen für superstreusel die sind
wirklich lecker wir haben kein komischen
Nachgeschmack man hat nicht das Gefühl
so oh Farbstoff oder sonst was ist es
richtig richtig lecker 7,90 € Nummer
zwei und zwar tschüss das ist so ein
richtiger Feen Knutscher
das vorletzte Türchen Nummer
so heißen die Streusel das ist aber ein
tolles farbmoto für einen Kuchen oder
wir Euro 3 und tschüss und damit kommt
jetzt schon das letzte Türchen ja
wir gibt es ist Heiligabend wir wollen
jetzt noch mal richtig die
Weihnachtsbäckerei anheizen und hoffen
dass superstreusel und jetzt versorgt
denn das Dessert was wir uns so
vorgestellt haben für Heiligabend hat
nicht so gut geklappt und jetzt brauchen
wir Plan B
[Musik]
ha ha ha
please oh nein oh nein oh nein das ist
das das hier das ist Karma das ist Karma
Liebe superstreusel Team toller
Adventskalender ich bin ein Fan vom
ersten Türchen an lieb ich den aber ein
Beutel ein Beutel ist kein 24 Türchen
das hat man zu Hause rumliegen wisst ihr
so so so schokomandeln die wirklich
festlich sind die hat man nicht zu Hause
rumliegen das hier hat man schon und
wenn jetzt noch mal mit Sally kommt und
dass sie auch ein Beutel drin hatte wer
hat diese Ironie und den Beutel nicht
verstanden ich dachte ich eigentlich
ganz klar und deutlich ausgedrückt aber
ja Beutel Beutel pack ich euch natürlich
in die verlosungsbox ne da denke ich
ganz klar an euch und dann euer Wohl
Kalender ist damit
auf sind alle verziert jetzt kommt der
große tastest noch mal zum Abschied wir
nehmen den ersten den wir hier so
vollgestopft haben
die sind noch nicht ganz durchgetrocknet
aber
diese Streusel sind wirklich next level
ja und jetzt kommen wir zum wichtigsten
Teil Preise zusammenrechnen
ich habe einen Preis vergessen den
Beutel was
berechnet bekommt 4 €, das ist unser
Lückenfüller okay wir bekommen
111 € und 63 raus das bedeutet dass wir
16 € gespart haben 16 € und es gibt
diese Größen nicht auf der Website das
heißt man kann wirklich viel mehr
Streusel ausprobieren und müsste sich
nicht immer 90 Gramm kaufen das finde
ich das finde ich echt gut 30 kann man
da jetzt gar nicht so wirklich was sagen
ich sag jetzt aber wie es ist für mich
ist der Kalender mega gut gelungen jetzt
außerdem 24 Türchen aber ich habe total
Spaß beim Entdecken der Streusel und der
sondersachen die ich noch so gar nicht
kannte ich habe jetzt richtig Lust zu
backen und das ist ja irgendwie toll
wenn du ein Adventskalender hast ja die
Lust aufs Backen macht und aufs
verzieren und Plätzchen dekorieren da
der Kalender schon ausverkauft ist und
ihr wahrscheinlich schon jetzt
mittlerweile alle ein hab kann ich
nichts weiter dazu sagen tolle super und
falls es super Streusel mal zusammen mit
mir arbeiten möchten ich kann die Sache
mit dem Beutel vergessen und dann gehen
wir gemeinsam in die Zukunft wisst ihr
warum ich das sage weil ich gesehen habe
dass Ross Antony der hat seine eigene
super streuselkollektion tropenträumchen
Gruselkabinett Frosti ich will auch eine
super streuselige Kollektion vielen Dank
dass ihr euch diese Staffel
Adventskalender auspackt Wahnsinn wieder
mal reingezogen habe das war jetzt hier
der letzte Adventskalender und es hat
mich mega gefreut dass das wieder so gut
bei euch angekommen ist wirklich ich
weiß gar nicht wie was ich sagen soll es
ist zu so einem großen Ding geworden ich
habe vor fünf sechs Jahren die ersten
Adventskalender ausgepackt und da habe
ich noch gar nicht kommen sehen was da
auf uns zukommt es macht einfach mega
Spaß ich liebe meinen absoluten
Kindheitstraum ich kann mein
Kindheitstrauma von den Adventskalendern
die ich nie hatte verarbeiten
mittlerweile kann ich halt also ich
brauche jetzt privat nicht wirklich ich
muss mal schauen was für ein
Adventskalender ich dieses Jahr haben
werde denn das ist ja auch noch spannend
ich habe schon eine Idee aber was ist
dann sein wird seht ihr bei blockbus
ne wirklich ne tschüssi abonniert meinen
Kanal falls es noch nicht gemacht habt
und guckt auch mal ein Video was nicht
ein auspack Videos okay